bonsoir nouvelle édition du 78 merci de
nous rejoindre en direct à 18h en ce 18
mars en plateau Bertrand Révillon
bonsoir à vous bonsoir vous êtes venu
récemment sur ce plateau c'était le 26
février dernier mais en tant que
journaliste pour parler de votre dernier
ouvrage conversation spirituelle
entretien avec des personnalités autour
de leur croyance vous êtes journaliste
mais aussi diacre du diocèse de
Versailles sur la paroisse de Montini
voisin le Bretonneux c'est à ce titre
que nous vous recevons ce soir pour
réagir à l'élection du nouveau pape
alors que demain doit se dérouler la
messe inaugurale et puis également sur
ce sujet nous devrions aussi avoir en
ligne tout à l'heure Christine Boutin la
présidente du parti chrétiendémocrate
par ailleurs conseillère général des
ivelines à noter que je recevrai aussi
ce soir des représentants de la FNACA
des yvelin la Fédération Nationale des
Anciens combattants en Algérie demain
pour la la première fois sera célébré la
Journée nationale du souvenir et du
recueillement à la mémoire des victimes
civiles et militaires de la guerre dans
ce pays en Tunisie et au Maroc également
voilà pour débuter je vous propose à
présent les titres les sujets que nous
allons aborder également en image au
cours de cette édition le ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire Benoît
amont est venu apporter son soutien à la
Croix-Rouge en visite à l'épisserie
sociale basée à trappe il a réaffirmé
l'importance du rôle des bénévoles dans
la cohésion sociale
une salle des festivités va être
construite à manilé ào avant la fin de
l'année la première pierre a été posée
ce samedi le bâtiment sera réalisé
majoritairement en bois une
écooréalisation l'écoot tril sur la base
de loisirs de 50 ans niveline a
rassemblé 8000 fondu de course à pied
les plus sportifs étaient invités à
parcourir 80 km un parcours qui les a
mené jusqu'à la tour Effel avec un
esprit résolument écologique le portrait
de la semaine celui de Sami benferlou
licencié au club club de kfou de Guy
encour à 23 ans il est devenu
vice-champion de France il prépare les
championnats du monde en octobre
prochain et pour le sport nous
retrouverons tout à l'heure Anthony rche
le point complet le 78 sport dans une
demi-heure bonsoir Anthony bonsoir
Wilfred au menu de ce 78 sport du
volleyball montinil bretonuse joue
actuellement sa survie en régional 1
l'entraîneur Abdelatif nichli sera avec
nous sur ce plateau pour faire un point
nous parleront aussi martio et KFU le
prodige Guillant courtois Sami benferlou
est revenu des championnats de France ce
weekend avec une B médaille d'argent et
puis comme d'habitude Wilfried tous les
résultats du weekend en fin d'émission
le 78 sport dans une petite demi-heure
pour l'instant nous passons au fait du
jour notre fê du jour les premiers pas
du pape
François demain mardi 19 mars le nouveau
pape François tiendra sa messe
inaugurale de témoignages de réaction
desè ce soir avec en plateau Bertrand
Révillon donc journaliste mais aussi
diacre dans les Yvelines sur la paroisse
de Montin est voisin et puis tout à
l'heure par téléphone la réaction
également de Christine Boutin la
présidente du Parti Chrétien Démocrate
tout d'abord Bertrand Révillon
qu'attendre de cette messe inaugurale
qui doit se dérouler demain c'est un
moment essentiel qui va lancer un petit
peu le le pontificat B c'est
l'installation du pape c'est la la prise
de fonction officielle au cours d'une
messe
euh c'est pas le jour où on va apprendre
de grandes décisions voilà c'est c'est
c'est une intronisation c'est une une
mise en route qui a déjà bien démarré je
trouve on en parlera justement vous
dites qui a bien démarré pourquoi ben
parce que déjà faisons un honorable nous
autres journalistes nous avions tous nos
petites fiches sur les papa Billy et on
s'est tous planté et nous n'avions
pratiquement aucun une fiche sur le
cardinal bergo gliot inconnu au
bataillon voilà qui nous surprend les
cardinaux réunis en conclave nous
surprennent et sortent de leur chapeau
un
homme qui pour le moment fait vraiment
un parcours sans faute est-ce que c'est
une bonne surprise alors pour vous ce
est surg je trouve c'est une très bonne
surprise parce que on sort on sort de
l'européanocentrisme si vous me passez
l'expression voilà le pape vient
traverse l'Atlantique vient de loin il
l'a dit lui-même en riant euh c'est un
homme qui connaît la grande pauvreté qui
a pas peur d'aller se balader dans les
bidonvilles euh c'est un pape social
c'est un pape qui n'a pas peur de
ferrailler avec les pouvoirs politiques
quand c'est pouvoirs politique oublie
les pauvres euh et c'est un homme simple
qui dès les premières secondes a je
dirais déshabiller la fonction papale
des oriposs de la puissance terrestre
voilà un homme qui commence par se faire
bénir par la foule qui s'incline devant
la foule voilà un homme qui se contente
d'une simple soutane blanche et qui on
l'a vu dimanche à la messe salue comme
un Curet de paroisse les chrétiens à la
sortie de de l'Eucharistie donc moi je
me réjouis parce que je crois que le
monde qu'on soit croyant ou pas croyant
je pense que le monde a a besoin de
signe fort voilà un homme qui met en
priorité l'urgence en direction des
pauvres j'en reviens à la messe
inaugurale Benoît 16 en 2005 dans son
homélie n'avait pas donné he de
programme vous nous le dites c'est pas
le moment où donne de toute façon de
prog en plus nous sommes en Carême donc
je ne m'attends pas à de grandes
déclarations mais en 2005 BO avait
appelé à l'unité de l'Église il avait
aussi répété le message de Jean-Paul II
le fameux n'ayez pas peur là vous vous
attendez un message différent à votre
avis qu'elles vont être les les grandes
ligne ou même de du discours de la
déclaration de demain de l'omélie de
demain je ne suis pas Madame Soleil euh
en tout cas ce que vous en attendez-vous
en tout peut-être en tant que diacre
également déjà le diacre est celui qui a
le souci des plus lointains euh voilà
qui a le souci des pauvres qui a le
souci du dialogue avec ceux qui ne font
pas partie de l'église qui sont loin et
je trouve que ce pape donne des signes
pas simplement catholique pratiquant
régulier il donne des signes au monde il
il donne un signe très fort en en disant
l'Église doit donner le le message de la
mensuétude de la compassion de de la
main tendue au plus pauvres et doit se
recessentrer sur le Christ et pas sur le
pape le pape nous a dit quand même ça
voilà et le choix du nom justement pape
François extraordinaire
là j'ai j'ai envie d'être papiste ce
soir parce que euh choisir François
François d'Assise François d'Assise est
quand même quand on relit l'histoire de
François d'Assise c'est quand même un
homme qui s'est libérer des pouvoirs
temporels qui venaient d'une famille
très riche qui acceptte de de se défaire
des oriposs du pouvoir de l'argent pour
vivre dans une très très grande pauvreté
et se recentrer sur la foi chrétienne
donc je trouve que c'est un patronnage
extrêmement fort on revient en image à
présent sur cette élection du nouveau
pape avec ce reportage que nous avons
réalisé la semaine dernière dernière
Julie Rocha soirè et l dioine qui se
sont rendus à guilloncour lors d'une
messe écoutez le témoignage du jeune
père Fabrice duet Abé mous Papam nous
avons un pape les catholiques vont
désormais célébrer chaque jour François
à l'église Saint-Victor de Guill encour
les fidèles étaient déjà émus avant la
messe ce jeudi midi je viens pour
remercier justement à Dieu pour
l'élection de Pape François prier je
suis très heureuse pour l'élection du
nouveau pape parce que ça donne une joie
à l'église d'avoir un pape d'un autre
continent mais qui est pour tout le
monde quelque chose de nouveau vous êtes
content oui madame un moment fort
partagé avec le jeune père Fabrice duet
qui vit son premier changement de
souverain pontif c'est une nouvelle
figure pour laquelle on va prier au
quotidien qui va pouvoir aussi donner
certaines directions à l'église et ja
PAP et ben arrive avec ses idées avec
des projets pour l'Église donc ça va
changer un certain nombre de choses même
s'il faut pas s'attendre à une
révolution majeure dans les quelques
semaines ce nouveau pape le pape
François et ben imprimera l'histoire de
l'Église à sa manière un pape jésuite
donc les Jésuites vous savez ce sont des
prêtres religieux qui ont fait le vœu de
pauvreté et qui vivent de manière assez
exigeante cette pauvreté François bah ça
fait référence à Saint-François d'Assise
Saint-François d'Assise et le saint par
excellence qui incarne la vertu de la
pauvreté qui incarne aussi l'amour de la
nature
l'amour le dialogue interreligieux
François saint-fançois avait été discuté
avec les musulmans à l'époque où ce
dialogue était plus que complexe donc ça
dit déjà fortement quelque chose de la
manière dont il sera pape en chaque
messe le pape est nommé on nomme le pape
et l'évêque par leur prénom alors tout
l'enjeu c'est de pas se tromper de pas
mettre notre PAP Benoît à ce moment le
pape François que tu as établi à sa tête
par Jésus le Christ notre
Seigneur sa première fois s'est bien
passé et restera un souvenir
extraordinaire tout comme la découverte
du pape hier soir au moment où j'ai
appris que la fumée était blanche je
recevais un couple en préparation au
mariage j'étais dans mon bureau au
presbytère donc je leur ai dit est-ce
que je crois qu'ils ont un peu halluciné
mais je leur ai dit est-ce qu'on peut
tout arrêter parce qu'il faut qu'on voit
le nouveau PAP puis je suis allé
chercher une bouteille de champagne et
donc avec ce couple on a débouché la
bouteille de champagne et accueilli le
nouveau pape et une fois seulement qu'on
savait qui c'était j'ai fermé mon
ordinateur et on a pu continuer la
préparation au mariage j'aimerais votre
réaction à ce qu'on vient d'entendre non
pas la bouteille de champagne pour
célébrer la r pourant je suis pas contre
le champagne moi non plus pour célébrer
l'arrivée du du nouveau pape mais
peut-être sur le fait de qu'il ne faut
pas s'attendre à une révolution dans
dans les semaines à venir mais en tout
cas il y aura du changement une
évolution lente l'église prend toujours
son temps alors par moment c'est un peu
agaçant on aimerait bien bien qu'elle
aille un peu plus vite elle avance elle
avance doucement
euh le pape ne peut pas changer l'église
en un jour parce que l'Église est
mondiale parce qu'il y a toutes les
sensibilités la manière de vivre le
christianisme en Europe et de la vivre
en Asie ou en Amérique du Sud n'est pas
la même et donc il faut avancer
lentement ce qui n'empêche pas des
gestes prophétiques et je crois que cet
homme est capable de geste prophétique
mais sur quel dossier très concret il
faudrait avancer il faudrait que
l'Église avance on peut penser au
préservatif on peut penser au mariage
homosexuel à l'avortement on sait que le
pape qui vient d'arriver le nouveau pape
François a des positions qui restent
dans la lignée de de l'église bien sûr
jusqu'à
présent je pense qu'il faut qu'il
avance il nous il nous a déjà donné ce
signe il faut qu'il avance vers une
église
plus en lien avec les pauvretés c'est
fondamental on a un déséquilibre Nord
Sud épouvantable on a des pays riches
qui continuent à se goinfrer pendant que
que la moitié voire les tris/4s de la
planète crèv de faim donc le principal
message c'est cela le Christ était
d'abord celui qui était proche des
pauvres voilà alors après notre nos
petites querelles internes alors le
préservatif la pilule et cetera
évidemment il faut il faut organiser je
souhaite qu'il y ait plus de débat sur
ces questions que ces questions ne
soient pas claquemuré fermé tabouiser
mais qu'on puisse les ouvrir mais
l'urgence elle est pas là euh l'urgence
elle est qu'est-ce que ce cette église
catholique a à dire au monde voilà on va
voir si les ivelinois partagent votre
point de vue justement c'est le micro
trotir que nous avons réalisé
aujourd'hui quelle évolution pour la
religion catholique
attendez-vous j'espère qu'il sera un
petit peu plus moderne avec des idées un
petit peu plus larges par rapport à la
vie des uns et des autres et de leur
choix de vie surtout je pense plus par
exemple à l'homosexualité voilà le
mariage gay des choses comme ça espérons
cro pas beaucoup hein aucune opinion
sauf que j'ai pu entendre quelque part
qui cherche à avoir une une église pour
pour les pauvres et donc ça serait
peut-être bien aussi que tous ces ce
lucre disparaisse voilà qu'elle soit
plus moderne j'aimerais aussi que que
les gens se bougent tout simplement pour
pour pour montrer qu'ils croi en en Dieu
et puis et puis qu'il soit heureux de ça
et voilà qu'elle s'ouvre un petit peu
plus sur le monde actuel qu'elle se
modernise un petit peut qu'elle permett
par exemple le mariage des prêtres je
pense que ce serait une bonne chose nous
continuons à évoquer donc cette élection
du nouveau pape et puis également cette
mess inaugurale qui doit se tenir demain
19 mars nous avons en ligne Christine
Boutin bonsoir à vous bonsoir bonsoir
présidente du Parti Chrétien déémocrate
conseillère général desivveline
qu'attendez-vous de cette messe
inaugurale tout simplement de de demain
bah écoutez c'est un moment spirituel
naturellement fort pour les catholiques
puisque c'est l'installation du paple
PAP va vraiment devenir pape demain et
c'est un jour important puisque c'est la
fête de Saint- Joseph qui est pour les
catholiques est une fête importante en
tant que présidente du Parti Chrétien
déémocrate jusqu'à présent est-ce que
vous vous retrouvez dans dans la ligne
de conduite que s fixé ce ce nouveau
pape on parle on en parlé d'ailleurs sur
ce plate tout à l'heure de d'un PAP plus
proche aussi des des plus pauvres par
exemple écoutez oui bien sûr moi je je
suis vous savez que au Parti chréti
démocrate le fondement même de notre
engagement c'est le plus fragile et le
plus vulnérable donc bien sûr
l'engagement de de François du
Saint-Père François va bien sûr tout à
fait dans notre lignée la préoccupation
le le politique devrait avoir comme
priorité de s'occuper du plus fragile et
du plus vulnérable donc a priori bien
sûr mais vous savez euh il y a une
continuité le pape Jean-Paul II était le
pape de l'espérance le pape benoî 16 et
celui de la foi et le pape François et
celui de la charité et sur celui de sur
certains des dossiers de société
véritablement parce que on vous a
entendu récemment très souvent dans
l'actualité réagir que ce soit par
exemple sur sur la question du mariage
pour pour tous on sait que la position
du du pape est très tranchée encore sur
cette question hein c'est le quotidien
Le Monde qui faisait un petit peu le
point sur ces différentes positions sur
le mariage homosexuel sur le
préservative sur l'avortement contre le
mariage des prêtres également vous vous
retrouvez dans cette ligne de conduite
et vous êtes satisfaite de cette ligne
qui est qui sera sans doute réaffirmé
encore ces ces prochains mois écoutez je
je pense que surtout dans les IIM vous
ne serez pas surprise que je sois
satisfaite de cette orientation euh
depuis toujours depuis mon engagement
depuis 30 ans en vie politique ça a été
pour la défense du profè AG donc de la
vie en particulier d' Bron donc
naturellement je suis heureuse de voir
que ce mais je neen suis pas surprise
quelquore été le fr ça été la même chose
le le respect de du plus fragile donc de
l'embryon le le respect aussi de la
famille qui est en train de se détruire
par la négation de la différence
sexuelle donc tout ça me paraît parfait
mais si en plus il peut y avoir une
dimension social de charité de partage
vous saz que j'ai fait un rapport sur la
globalisation et qui insiste sur le la
la comment dirais-je la répartition des
biens sur le fondement même de la du don
et de la gratuité moi personnéement je
me retrouve parfaitement sur ces deux
lignes de de CRESS je me retrouve et le
Parti Chrétien-Démocrate s'y retrouve
parfaitement une toute dernière question
il y a eu cette polémique aussi he dè la
semaine dernière autour de l'attitude du
pape par rapport à son passé par rapport
au dictateurs Videl là aussi en
Argentine vous aviez d'ailleurs déclaré
tout homme est supérieur à son péché
c'était sur le plateau de de LCP la la
semaine dernière vous comprenez moins
que ça puisse interpeller aussi les
personnes qui ne sont tout simplement
aussi pas croyantes de voir se se passer
ressurgir du du pape ou écoutez je je je
confirme mais en plus si vous voulez on
s'est aperçu que le pape François qui
était à l'époque n'était même pas évec
était un simple curé donc ce qu'on lui a
reproché il nétait même pas en situation
de pouvoir pour
pouvoir faire ce qu'on lui reprochait
donc c'est tombé complètement ça une
critique immédiate qui a été lancée pour
faire une polémique mais ce n'était
absolument pas fondé sur le plan
historique je crois même qu'il y a un
des deux prêtres qui étent visés des
Jésuites en question qui a fait une
déclaration très claire qui est vivant
encore et qui a fait une déclaration
très claire pour dénoncer tous ces
amalgames et dire que c'était
complètement faux mais historiquement
même ce n'est pas contestable
historement c'est pas possible ce qu'on
lui reprochait n'était pas possible
merci Christine Bouttin je maintien un
homme est toujours supérieur à son péché
merci Christine Bouttin d'avoir été en
ligne avec nous président du Parti
Chrétien Démocrate également conseillère
général des zveline Bertrand Révillon
merci d'avoir été avec nous une dernière
question également pour vous faire
réagir sur ce début de polémique qui a
commencé la la semaine dernière autour
du passé oui je suis d'accord avec ce
que vient de dire Christine Boutin
effectivement il y a une polémique qui
n'est pas fondée puisque au moment des
faits euh le cardinal Bergoglio qui
n'était pas cardinal était provincial
des Jésuites et et n'habitait pas la
capitale je pense que ce sont des hommes
qui agissent dans l'ombe c'est un homme
timide c'est un homme réservé c'est un
homme qui fait pas de publicité sur ce
qu'il a fait il a son sans doute fait
beaucoup dans l'ombre discrètement les
faits qui lui sont reprochés ne me
paraissent pas du tout crédibles merci
bertrandion d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle votre ouvrage he conversation
spirituelle qu'on peut toujours se
procurer et puis vous collaborez
également avec psychologie.com on peut
retrouver vos interview sur le site
internet demain mardi ce sera donc la
messe inaugurale pour le pape mais aussi
la date anniversaire du CC le feu en
Algérie c'était en 1962 on va en parler
dans un instant avec des représentants
de la fnaka du département des evelines
mais déjà le point sur cette visite
aujourd'hui de Benoît Hamont attrape
entre projet de loi cadre de sur le
développement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et puis scandale alimentaire
également le ministre en charge de ces
différents dossiers a beaucoup
d'actualité en ce moment mais il était
tout de même à trappe ce matin pour
soutenir la Croix-Rouge et puis cette
petite information en plus également
sachez que Benoît amont par ailleurs élu
député de la circonscription des
ivelines la 11e circonscription s'est
incliné ce weekend avec le 15 de rugby
parlementaire c'était face à
l'Écosse Eugénie Pau va terminer dans 2
semaines son service civique cette
étudiante en histoire et Communication a
mené à terme son contrat de 9 mois à
raison de 24 heures par semaine ça a été
une expérience très
enrichissante pour moi une première
expérience professionnelle en fait ça
m'a fait découvrir le monde associatif
le
bénévolat voilà la réalité aussi enfin
sur le
terrain réalité sociale en fait avant
d'être volontaire a débuté comme
bénévole à la Croix Rouge de 50 an en
Yveline elle vient épauler les 15 autres
bénévoles de l'épicerie sociale basée à
trappe ici il y a à faire près de 1400
familles aidées en 2012 sans les
bénévoles on aurait le pays sera encore
plus divisé et cabossé qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui en visite ce lundi matin le
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire est donc venu se rendre compte
du travail quotidien et plus largement
apporter son soutien aux associations
caritatives la loi de finance va à la
fin de l'année devrait prévoir une
mesure pour réduire les impositions sur
salaire nous réfléchissons à une mesure
qui permette
d'aligner le niveau des impôts payés par
ces associations sur celui des grandes
entreprises privées qui elles ont
bénéficié du crédit d'impôt et qui ainsi
ont pu économiser des centaines de
milliers d'euros et comme les
associations ne payent pas d'impôt sur
les sociétés mais de la taxe sur les
salaires ell réclament pour les gros en
tout cas une mesure
d'équivalence une mesure qui si elle est
actée devrait donner plus d'air au
association caritative et elles en ont
bien besoin en cette période de crise où
les demandes de soutien AFF flu sur le
secteur de Saint-Quentin en Yveline une
autre problématique est apparu depuis
l'été dernier l'augmentation du nombre
de réfugiés de l'Est et d'Afrique ils
sont aujourd'hui entre 200 et 300 aidés
directement par la Croix-Rouge tout ce
qu'on fait en direct on est aidé par
personne donc là c'est nous qui
supportons la totalité des dépenses et
ça pour une première année depuis que je
suis président nous terminons
l'année plutôt en déficite qu'autre
chose l'épicerie sociale de trappe est
ouverte d'orénavant à raison de 5
demi-journé par
semaine